[Music]
working at the council is indeed quite
special because it is a new institution
but really it is the place where
European politics is shaped every day
it's the place where the action is it's
the place where you leaders meet where
world leaders come to visit all the time
we have a lot of press and media
attention and a lot of journalists in
this building so I think also for
trainees it's a really great experience
to see how Europe works at the highest
political level one of the main things
that I really liked about the
traineeship was the fact that we were we
were not that many trainees compared to
the other institutions in the other
institution there are hundreds of
trainees but here at the council we were
only 60 or so so we really became like a
tight-knit group we kind of like made a
little family for ourselves here and
then really got to know each other and
you know build this network and I think
that was one of the main take outs and
also what Alexandra said about being at
the heart of European politics also one
of the amazing things all European
citizens can apply who have at least a
bachelor degree the main aim of or
traineeship is just that both trainees
and or institution benefits from it so
trainees got a meaningful work and they
get a deeper understanding of the work
of the council and the EU and the
council benefit from the fresh input
from the trainees
[Music]
there's no age limit although I have to
say the most of - or trainees are young
graduates what we are we also welcome
other people who are changing their
careers or they're purchasing lifelong
learning so they are also very welcome
to apply as well the eligibility
criteria is that you need to have
finished your first cycle of studies
that means three years of university
studies which results in a bachelor
degree and you should have earned a
bachelor degree before applying but it's
okay if you don't have the degree in
your hand until you sign the traineeship
agreement we also have another
traineeship program which we call
compulsory traineeship as part of your
studies the conditions are different the
main difference is that you don't need
to have a degree in order to apply but
all the conditions and the criteria is
explained on your website you can apply
and you can get in as a trainee
even with solely the knowledge of
English but then we also had a lot of
friends in the traineeship group who
were mainly speaking French during their
work hours and during their time as a
trainee so it really depends and a lot
of people knew both languages so it's
really a mixture of like English
speakers mainly French speakers and then
you know both and it's very common to
people have several languages that they
speak the more languages you speak the
more first style you are so you don't
have to have French for example but it's
very useful if you do because you can
just do more stuff you can work on more
assignments whenever we would be looking
at candidates for traineeships we would
really also look at there at the
languages that they had and indeed I
mean we asked you owner to come and work
with us so for us French is not an
absolute requirement but it is really
good if you have it because in the
council a lot of French is still spoken
I feel but let's say that you don't have
French but you have another super useful
language may be Greek or maybe Finnish
or another language that can also be a
real asset
you see lots of applications from well
candidates with a background in EU
policy low international relations but
we also need trainees in information and
technology logistics meetings all these
kind of fields which are needed to run
the council during the application you
have to select your first preference and
second preference and there is a quite a
long list of preferences domains
available and these domains mirror the
activity of the council tivity in the
policy field but also in the
administration communication translation
professional experience is not not
required so it can also apply without
any professional experience if you have
the bachelor bachelor degree and it's
what you indicate as your domain first
domain and second domain is really up to
you up to your interest up to your
motivation so it can perfectly happen
that your studies are different what you
are interested in now but of course your
applications should be consistent so you
should have a deep knowledge of the view
of the domain what you are choosing for
I would really look at motivation and
try to see okay have these people done
their research have say you know checked
our website do they know roughly what
we're doing and is their motivation
quite strong I mean if it's just a
generic motivation saying oh this looks
interesting to me that's maybe not so
convincing but if people have clear
points even though they might lack the
experience in the field I can still be
be persuaded to pick somebody just
because you know it's not really fair to
ask of a ton of experience from people
who are just starting their career so I
totally get that I'd find that thing
that makes you unique find that thing in
your studies or your life in general and
your work experience that makes you
stand out and highlight that because
then there are a lot of applicants make
yourselves you know special
[Music]
we need a lot of extra hands on that we
need a lot of help watching social media
tracking you know seeing what what
journalists are saying about us trying
to sort of anticipate the news cycle and
trainees have played a super valuable
role in this regard because they've
really been our eyes and ears and they
help us to keep track of the huge volume
of communication that's happening about
the summit and then we're able to based
on all of the work they do were able to
in yeah inform our political principles
much better so that's also something
that I think trainees need to realize is
that our aim is not just to have you you
know there in the office and just look
on from the sidelines but really you're
gonna be doing a real job there are
tough days you you work hard you work
long hours but it's also very very
rewarding because you you get to be
really close to what is what is
happening that day what is decided that
they what is talked about that day
monitoring the media monitoring Twitter
social media and this is true you get to
get quite close to the leaders I would
usually come in at 9 o'clock depending
on the day sometimes if there's a summit
or a preparations for a summit then you
then you come in earlier but it's
usually an eight-hour workday but that
Secretariat that also varies a lot
because as I said if their summits if
there's something very important days
might drag on and that's that's normal
it really depends some days were a
little bit slower then I had more time
to do research and to teach myself new
things and then other days it was really
full-on press conferences running from A
to B to C to D and yeah but really as
Alexandra also mentioned earlier it is
it is full-on work
[Music]
a lot of it comes down to your the
accommodation that you're gonna get in
Brussels there's a number of options so
some places are expensive and some
places are less expensive where you're
gonna we're gonna live here but that
that is gonna take some chunk of the
money but there is gonna be money left
and and I think I lived you know in in a
nice manner with with the the money that
I received from the council I I had some
savings before I came here and I only
dipped into them just a little bit if I
get this it is sufficient enough amount
of money to have a social life to go to
the cinema to have a drink go to a
concert and yeah you can really live a
rich social life as well with the money
that you receive from the council
[Music]
usually we select 50 trainees so
applications and closes 16th of October
and then we start right away with the
selection procedure so the selection
will be ongoing in November December and
or aim is to contact selected trainees
before end of the year I mean that's the
aim sometimes happens that we are not
able to do that and we are still in
January and we are still contacting
potential potential trainees in January
but the aim is that to finish the
selection and have to select the
trainees by the end of the year if you
are selected or if you are on a
shortlist and invited for a phone
interview or on an interview then we
send you an email and if you are
selected you receive a traineeship offer
and through those trainee those
candidates who are not we're not
selected they will receive an email at
the end of the selection procedure
[Music]
during the years you see trainees who
have been at I mean they're coming back
in another professional capacity they
become delegates for a permanent
representations and processors they work
for NGO of King tanks or they come back
as working for the council quite a good
number of trainees stay on in browsers
and find find a job after they finish
appear we recently had a new colleague
join us in the web team and I had met
him the first time when he was on his
tail end of his traineeship and I had
just started in the press office it's
really fun to see people come back
because it I think it's a sign that this
the time they spent here was a good time
was a useful times I think the main
thing is that you need to be proactive
and you need to be open and you need to
be you really need to show the people
you work with that you're willing to
learn new things and that you yourself
have your own ideas that and you want to
contribute to the working environment
not just like I'm here to follow orders
obviously you need to know how to do
that as well but but really to push push
forward the fact that you are willing to
contribute something to the working
environment so be proactive that will be
my main tip a good trainee is definitely
somebody who is ready to work and to
work hard but who's also honest and open
when things don't really go as planned
when they struggle with something or
when they cannot meet a deadline or they
need some extra help because honestly
although we're trying to give you an
authentic work experience we also want
you to learn we want you to be able to
grow and benefit from this experience
[Music]
I would just say that apply and come
here because it's law it's a lot of fun
it's really you learn a lot and you
improve as an as an employee and
something that I have noticed applying
for jobs after afterwards there's a lot
more callbacks after used on the
traineeship so it really hit really pays
off to as you said in the beginning
leave your life and move to Brussels so
it's I do not regret that at all
[Music]